[Music]
Welcome folks uh to the building
protected MCP servers session. Uh I'm
Den Delmarski. I'm a product engineer at
Microsoft uh and member of the MCP
steering committee. and I'm Julia and I
work in Azure API management at
Microsoft and the both of us are part of
an MCP squad at Microsoft. So I guess
that's why we are here. Yeah. Um so
we're going to again talking about
protected MCP servers and uh why why is
this even important? Why is this even a
topic? Well, the thing is when we talk
about MCP servers and MCP servers that
folks connect to their whatever clients,
whether it's Cloud Desktop, VS Code, VS,
not every server should be open because
there's a bunch of different APIs that
might require authorization. They're
protected. So, naturally, your MCP
server needs to be able to do the same.
Uh, it is super important for remote MCP
servers because anybody can access them
and especially if the servers are open
to the broad internet, not behind a VPN.
uh but it's not really relevant for
local servers uh and mainly because
locally you can do a bunch of stuff
already because it's just a binary and
we'll get to that in a second. Now, um,
if you're building MCP servers and
remote MCP servers specifically, one of
the things that you are connecting to
are likely thirdparty APIs, whether it's
your own or somebody else's, and that
API requires user context. That API
needs to know who's invoking it because
different customers have different
permissions. You might have different
admin policies. Uh so while your API
does control through the help of an
identity provider as you who actually
has access uh this needs to be somehow
exposed to the MCP layer. Uh and of
course your API will act differently
depending on the credentials that you
give it. If I'm an admin I get access to
a certain set of tools. If I'm somebody
that's just a contributor I get access
to a bunch of different tools. Now, all
these things considered, one of the
questions I get asked a lot is like,
well, okay, this is all great for
remote, but why not local? Why what's
the story for authorization for local
servers? And the answer is kind of
simple. Local servers are binaries on
the box. They're binaries that run
within the context of whatever machine
you have. That means that they can do O
in any way you can possibly have. Like,
it doesn't need to be O. You can have
credentials that are secrets. You can
have certificates. You can have pass
keys that are bound to whatever
credential you have in the box. Like
it's just like you don't have any
constraints whatsoever. Um that means
that any APIs you connect to can also be
done you know in any way with any of the
off-the-shelf libraries. Uh there's of
course special cases here if you do
things like remote desktop and all sorts
of kind of multi-user scenarios on VMs.
Uh but that's kind of out of scope for
MCP. That's something that we left the
implementers. Now remote servers. Let's
get back to that. So one of the things
that if you've browseed kind of the MCP
specs you might know that we have two
different specifications. There's one
that is stable that is March 26 uh and
there's one that is draft that we worked
very closely with a bunch of security
experts to refine. So for the previous
specification the one that is currently
marked as stable MCP required people
that are building MCP servers to
essentially spin up their own
authorization server. That means you are
building your own token factory. So if
you want to issue um tokens to an MCP
client to authorize users, you're the
one that has to craft those tokens and
manage them and refresh them and sign
them. Very complicated. It required
people to actually be OATH experts. Like
if you want to build an MCP server that
does OOTH, you need to understand how OT
works end to end, including to the point
of minting those tokens, which is very
complicated. So the draft spec that we
worked with Enthropic and a bunch of
security experts to refine actually does
this clean separation between the server
the MCP server which we call the
resource server and the authorization
server. So things like token minting and
managing token lifetime actually is not
done by the MCP server anymore. It's
done by whatever authorization server
you're using. So if you're using octa
ozero entry ID it doesn't really matter.
You can just plug it in a GMCB server
and it's gonna work with the client that
those servers can connect to. And the
spec, by the way, is going to be stable
very soon. Now, I want to hand it off to
Julia to talk about the fact that not
every developer wants to be on security
expert, right? Like we've seen the
current draft now the new one that's
about to go live into production. But
not everyone, we have some exceptions
here um who do want to become security
experts, you actually want to focus on
building the remote MCP server, right?
You want to solve a real problem. So
this is why the new authorization spec
um and that's why Dan why a PE a bunch
of people at Microsoft we partner
partnered with anthropic in a security
um committee to get this new offsp spec
out there. So let's see if I paid
attention. What are some of the core
things that's going to change now moving
forward? First of all, no need to
implement the authorization servers
anymore. So, um that means we can now
just rather than implementing it from
scratch, we can actually attend it or
append it to our server overall. We can
use the standard ways. We only need to
reference metadata that are going to
point to our authorization servers and
they that's where we're going to get the
token and then on server side you're
going to have the token that information
here and all of this are still going to
continue standard OOTH 2.0. So we can
actually as developers we can rely on
all of the libraries that are already
out there all of the services. So it's
going to make our lives a lot a lot of
easier. What does this also include on
client side? So on client side they are
now in a way responsible for the end to
end token dance. So this means if the
authorization code comes in and we can
validate or the client validates first
of all is the token has it been um
acquired successfully and then on server
it's going to pass it through to the
server and on server side which is still
very important um you're going to have
to make sure if it's been validated
correctly. Um and also of course on
server side we have to implement um the
metadata which we which I previously
just talked about. So again a lot a lot
of um yeah enhancements now moving
forward with the new spec saving effort
saving or saving keystrokes as
developers they don't need to write a
lot of security code because again it's
the risk is higher. Exactly. If you're
not a security expert and you start
implementing security code what are the
chances that you're going to get it
right on the first shot? 100%. and you
can start relying on these offshelf
identity providers like Microsoft Entra,
Octa. So all of these things and you
it's just going to be less work for the
developer. But yeah, how does it work in
practice? Yeah, so let let's talk about
so we talked about the new spec and for
folks that might be a little confused
like what the heck is the new spec and
how exactly works. So in a new spec um
there's a very clear separation of
interaction between the MCP client, MCP
server and the authorization server. So
in this case what happens your MCP
client like let's say cloud desktop is
going to request data from the MCP
server the MCP server at that point
because the MCP client doesn't have any
user context yet is going to respond
back with a standard HTTP 401 saying I
have no idea who you are at my server is
protected but here's a pointer to
something that we call the PRM the
protected resource metadata document
that's embedded in one of the headers in
dubdub authenticate that's going to say
but you can go here and learn more about
how to authorize against me the MCP
server. So the MCP client again claude
desktop or VS code or any other
variation will then talk to the uh the
take the PRM extract from that PRM
information about what authorization
server it's using whether it's octa zero
entra keycloak it doesn't really matter
and it's going to then I again I
abstracted this out in a very simplistic
way step four complete flow but
basically the client is going to do the
whole oath discovery step by step go
through the dance get the token And then
it's going to request data with a token
from the server and the server is going
to return it back. The client is
responsible for completing this entire o
dance where the server now doesn't
actually need to manage tokens. You only
need to make sure that you're validating
them. I call out this thing called a
PRM. And the PRM is something hosted by
the MCP server that is essentially a
JSON document. There's variation. And it
could be a JSON web token, but for the
purpose of this conversation, it's
basically a JSON document that says,
hey, I am this resource. I'm this
server. And by the way, my authorization
servers are the following. And it can
give a list of servers. It can specify
things like bare methods supported as
well as scopes. So the client when it
gets this document knows exactly how to
bootstrap the end to end authorization
flow with all standard O. You can use
offtheshelf libraries for for doing
this.
Uh let's eat an action in C# and because
we're Microsoft, of course, it's going
to be C#. Uh you know, uh so uh this is
currently in a uh in a pull request for
the C# for the official MCP C# SDK. By
the way, uh to show you just how easy it
is to set up an MCP server that is
protected by an OOTH provider, by an
identity provider, I have essentially an
ASP.NET Core application. It could work
for any other application. But what I'm
doing is all I'm configuring is add
authentication to make sure that I'm
actually adding O to my server. I'm
saying that it's using the MCP O scheme.
I'm adding some validation logic that
again is built into the framework.
Oh no,
I see I see what the problem is. I Great
call out. Yeah.
See, it's a fantastic demo. I'm going to
duplicate my screen. That's That's I
think what's going to do. There we go.
All right. So, say it again. Uh I'm
adding authentication. I'm adding MCP
authentication defaults here because
it's all baked into the framework. I'm
adding some logic to validate the jot
the token and this is again standard
embedded into the framework components.
Uh I have some metadata events that are
relevant here. And then I'm saying add
MCP. And within ADM MCP I'm saying that
I'm adding some PRM metadata that I just
talked about which is my server
supporting header O. And because I'm
using entra ID can be again octa zero.
I'll specify the metadata and that's it.
And then I'll say use authentication use
authorization. There's a lot of
boilerplate code here because it's an
MCP server that uses again the the stock
SDK. But the a that's the complexity.
That's all. I needed to add this
metadata and that's kind of it. when I
start the server. So, it's going to run
locally. Let's take this on.
And what I'm going to do now is I'm
going to go to the browser here. Got to
refresh this. And you'll notice that
this is the PRM that I talked about. I
have a local host server. It says my
authorization server is log to
microsoftonline.com because I'm using
entra ID. Again, it could be any of
them. I define the scopes and I say that
it's using header. That's it. That's
what the server says to the client in
terms of O. Now I have another instance
here that is the client and the client
definition with the C# SDK. Again, it's
super super simplistic. What I have here
is I'm essentially on the client side
say saying that I'm using a generic O
provider. There's nothing Microsoft
specific here. It's generic OT. I'm
specifying the client ID for my MCP
client, some scopes, and that's kind of
it. The rest is standard boilerplate for
transport setup as you would with any
other client. This client is already set
up to connect to my test server, my
local server. So, if I run this,
let's see, is it going to connect? It's
going to go ahead and discover the
metadata document. It actually went
really fast because I'm already
authorized here. Perfect demo. Um, but
behind the scenes, it actually what it
did is it did request the token from
Entra ID. It verified it sent the token
to the server. The server verified it
and then invoked a tool that I had on
the MCP server and said that there's no
alerts. It's a simple weather example.
It's nothing too complex here. But the
end to end developer experience here is
extremely simple. Like we worked very
very hard to not expose any of the
security intricacies to developers. You
just that that's all you do. So C# SDK
it's there. It's in a PR. It's going to
be in production very very soon. So uh
Julia, do you want to talk about VS Code
and API management? Yeah, totally. So
okay, we saw this working locally now.
We've used the libraries. So what if you
now want to take it to production? I
might be biased because I'm part of the
Azure API management team, but I always
recommend putting a gateway in between
to make it more secure and actually use
it to protect um and secure your remote
MCP servers. Um, so what I'm going to
show you today is um, for this we have a
public available GitHub repository out
there. Um, it's going to help you and
it's going to spin up an example. Um,
and in our example, let's scroll down
and go to the overview here. Um, we're
going to use Azure API management in the
middle to do and help with um,
authentication. Um,
the beauty about this example is it only
uses an ACD up. So we wanted to give
developers especially we've heard a lot
of um complaints about sometimes it
takes some time. So we wanted to go
super fast. So with an ACD app it will
spin up all of the resources. So while
I'm doing this and everything is going
to be um deploying here. Let's talk a
little bit about what is going to be set
up under the hood and what's going to
help make our remote MCP server um more
secure. So as I've mentioned Azure API
management as your remote MCP proxy um
we we are hosting it our remote MCP
server on Azure where we have three
tools implemented. We want to make sure
the connection here is secured and
that's where we're going to use the
gateway in between to help us do the
dance. And for this we have an oth API
that's going to help the play between
our identity provider. In our case it's
Microsoft enter ID that's going to help
essentially with the login and also the
consent flow here to truly make sure
that the um connection here is secured
to our back end to our remote MCP
server. Right. All right. So let's see
um how the deployment of my resources
resources are looking. I told you it
truly only takes maybe five minutes max.
Um it does spin a bunch of other things
like um an app service plan log
analytics to make sure that this is
truly production ready and it um gives
you a way to monitor and also analyze
and log it. So I'm going to copy my
endpoint here. before I'm going to do
something with it, let's just check on
Azure API management side if all of the
things have been implemented correctly.
Because what we should see now in my
APIs tab is we should see the the
endpoint to my remote MCP server which
is the MCP API and also the endpoint
that's going to help us handle o and of
course while the spec evolves we also
going to evolve the samples and all of
it that comes with it. So let's test it.
I'm going to start MCP inspector here.
Um let's open MCP um inspector um and
provide the URL endpoint. So once I
connect now what I should see is um if I
click the connect button here this is
going to pop up my consent page. Right?
So it's going to show the application
name. It's going to make sure that I'm
providing the right content. I'm going
to allow access to it. The first time
I'm doing it. I also have to um provide
the right permissions. So I'm going to
going to accept this here and once I'm
back now you can see I'm actually
connected and now I'm going to list the
tools and as we talked about it I
currently just have three tools
implemented here. All right, VS Code,
how does it work? Actually, now in VS
Code, for example, VS Code has MCP
support as well. I'm just going to
provide the endpoint and I'm going to
find a name for my MCP remote server
here, which let's call it AI engineer.
And it's going to add it to my user
settings. And immediately, it's going to
start running it. And you can see now in
VS Code, because they now also support
OOTH, they're going to pop up the
window. they going to show a
notification about hey let's
authenticate towards it I'm going to
open it and we're going to see the same
consent page right this time with VS
code different application name here
where we are again we're going to um
provide our um consent we're going to
allow it and now back I'm authorized I'm
allowed to use it in VS Code Insider so
once that's done you saw now I have
access to the three tools here in VS
Code so let's test this what it's going
to do when copilot studio
GitHub copilot um so first I'm going to
select and see perfect it's um it was
able to select my tools and it's um able
to detect these and now once I start
interacting I I have my text prompt here
and just kind of do the hello worlds um
very simple example um GitHub copilot is
now going to run it it's going to detect
the tool because I've been um
authenticated it's going to run it um
hopefully successfully perfect and now
we can also double check so if I open
the tool calling here I can see that the
output of hello I'm an MCP tool has been
successfully um provided
um something new and I know the world is
spinning very very fast so as being part
of Azure API management we want to make
it easier as well so we know the
similarities between MCP servers and
APIs so one of the latest announcements
that we have done is you can now also
start transforming your REST APIs into
remote MCP servers using our tools you
using our um platform here and you can
configure your already existing endpoint
rest endpoints into tools that you want
to expose to get like um VS code um and
we're going to do this all with our
platform because we want to make it
easier for enterprise customers but also
developers to get started with this. So
here in my use case um I just copied the
endpoint that was provided by me um by
API management. I'm going to hit start
and running. Um of course always make
sure to implement O and that's the
beauty about our platform. You can use
it for securing it and but also for
hosting in this case. And now I'm able
to also just immediately call it and
let's just check if um GitHub Copilot
was able to detect the MCP server here.
Perfect. You can see it right under my
service AI engineering one. I'm seeing
the three tools that is all based on my
REST API in VS Code and now I'm ready to
go and interact with it um in VS Code
right here. With this being said, um
lots of things are changing in this
space.
Any um good words for the people out
there who want to get started with
remote MCP server? Yeah, so uh there's
links on the screen that you can go to.
These are the specification documents uh
that you can learn more about how MCP o
works. We also have a document that we
partner with anthropic on that's called
security best practices that outline
what are the best practices that you
should be adopting in your MCP server.
You want to make sure that you're not
pawned. Uh very very important. And then
I'll also mention that uh starting with
VS Code Insiders, we do support the new
authorization spec. So you should check
it out, download it, install it, give us
your feedback, and if anything doesn't
work, we have Harold at this conference
who can help you debug it. So, thank you
folks. It's great. Stop by at the booth.
Yeah.
[Music]